hey guys welcome back to another episode
of Friends oh now let's see if foul
calls okay he was hurt last time I want
to see if he's okay let's do this let's
do this ah mr. benét's getting his paws
wet right okay where would he have gone
oh we haven't been here ya go fishing
rod well how did we miss this place okay
fine what's the fishing rod for mmm
catching fish maybe maybe we can use it
can we combine it with the feather
broken fishing rod it's a broken one ah
soon probably won't be able to use it
what's that the next water is very clear
is there anything can you see anything
wonder why there's a fish in there maybe
it's the season oh oh look at this we're
an ice she's like no I don't want to go
a nice okay hey he's in the boat now
he's fishing huh I would like to borrow
the boat what about this season hey now
we can get in the boat I'm not kitty get
in the boat we're going for a ride fun
we've totally forgot my phone call
already ah and surely we find for a
little bit he's a doctor he's a doctor
guys he'll be fine oh okay so is this
the crystals that we need to get cuz
we've already got one of the items that
we need to get we need to get three more
items oh wow something about the island
kitty I wonder if somebody could live
there really it's tiny maybe an ant I
guess tiny creatures like almost
invisible one you me and Frank we share
the same mind um so or what what do you
want me to do should I try and use this
oh I can keep on going left okay hey hey
this is how we get our clothes as well
okay sweet go on Fran so we can fix the
bridge we can take a crystal candy fixes
i'll leave it there oh i thought we
needed a christophe one of the things
perhaps not perhaps i didn't figured out
perhaps i didn't figure out the riddle
as well as i thought it but here's our
clothes anyway so let's go get them
kitty i can't find my pills we need the
pills guys is gonna start getting creepy
again maybe the pills aren't here maybe
you lost them well they weren't doing me
any good anyways ah we're not gonna get
creepy not this episode maybe next
episode maybe they'll appear someday
let's keep going now okay come to your
one and only wearer she's funny ok cool
so can't take it off this this crystal
step back in the boat then let's go
right let's go and see how falcons doing
that was that was our main mission and
I'm sorry I got conclusive Fran I have
the one thing you desire I have what
you're looking for
husa my oh my gosh is her mom I was
gonna joke mommy is that you mummy it
was so sweet and cute for so long wow I
beloved daughter can close and let me
feel you don't do it he's disguised his
tongue to look like your mum don't do it
there's nothing to be afraid of you have
to compose a friend don't let it kiss
you fried don't do it you can't be my
mother she's dead you have to come
closer now if you don't the big monster
will come and get you you're not my
mummy leave me alone good yes Fran my
darling the big monster will come and
get you he will come and get you you
will come and get you
mommy you're scaring me please stop it
so looks like I absolutely lied about
the creepy stuff not happening this
episode it happened enjoy it I enjoyed
it oh dear it's so it's so cool because
this game it's like so innocent yet so
disturbing and it touches on so many
horrible horrible topics she go I mean
is it's the opposite ends of the scale
and it makes it so disturbing but anyway
let's let's carry on so let's go and
talk to this person up the stairs cuz
I'm when when we were up the stairs
there were some more stairs that we
could only go in the wintertime or
something I don't know look it's a
snowman hello mrs. Noem I'm are you
having fun should we see if we've got
anything we don't have a carrot or
anything to give him for a nose okay
what do i do i do hi out what I don't
stop right there do you have the
password there's a password now Oh No
what password the library password of
course you must have it to come inside
ah who knows password do you know who
has the password the great wizard of
course he knows everything hmm all right
i'll see if i can find the password but
so now we have to go back to the
freaking grow wizard so we can find the
password this is not cool alright let's
go back to the wizard asking what the
password is and also give him one of
those one of the fangs because the
feather was one of the things that we
were looking for one of the answers to
the riddles witch witch riddle was it
the answer to some black
oh it's number four number afar pick it
up use it with number four keys all
right no no no don't need him to explain
the riddles I want to ask him about the
password
ah maybe we should give him our clothes
I've smelly clothes I can't make you
human yet we have to find the first dome
darn it hmm can you fix you can you fix
this by any chance so look I found a
fishing rod it's broken can you help me
hmm let me see something is missing Lucy
the hook that goes with this rod huh you
just said the exact same thing someone
else did back in the hospital did he
it's been too long it's been too long
ready who well what hospital see Oswald
asylum sir like cuz obviously he knows
what that is Fran the nurse when I broke
the Khatun oh I have no idea what you're
talking about you don't quite strange I
love are one of the responses for you
yes for you yes I am strange well let's
forget about it can you please make me a
hook for the fishing but yes let's do it
did you give me a coin i can give you
half a hook ok let's go back to the old
snail guy and get some more coins you
give me two coins you'll get an entire
hook what's the point in half a hook I
don't need half [ __ ] I need the whole
thing the whole thing will cost you
three coins one coin for half a hook to
for the working one do you Oh sir you
are complicated but i'll bring your
coins ok cool I don't know why we need
to fix the fixed fleur the right but
whatever we're doing it I wish making
money was this easy just winning
tic-tac-toe
yeah all right let's let's win all the
Tic Tac toes I'll go for the middle
there's always the the go to the go-to
isn't it but sometimes the middle
doesn't work like last summer at the
middle and it didn't really work nah oh
you're gonna win I'm an idiot hurry up
you take too long yeah ah won one gold
coin at the gunning to get to the right
yeah okay we got three let's go thanks
old snail dude you are master let's go
spend this money wisely for you yeah
yeah he knows who you are but ok goodbye
right let's just give him the money
here are you three coins sir ah it was
through wonderful thank you and he is
your hook I hope it works fine thanks I
still don't know why I need a hook no
well whatever thank you so it's perfect
i have to go now bye okay I'm we combine
it with the broken hmm oh oh oh she
needs something to so now I'm gonna have
to get another girl coin because I need
some thread hello miss and what if you
have some French so the fishing line do
you fishing like yes yes I have some do
you want it oh yes please how much is it
well quite a lot is that good I meant
price-wise I only need enough for a
fishing line oh I forgot to think about
a price you see I've never solves
anything before see Fran was white it
sadly don't wear clothes but you know
what you can have it if it I hope it
makes you happy oh thanks she's so sweet
there's all these other people like Oh
work three gold coins thank you Miss i
hope you settle some prices and sell
something soon bye sweet ok so let's
let's fix fix the raj and then combine
this
that I did it this is grand I'll call
you the fish the what the fish eggs cool
suburb of what what are we trying to do
with this exactly don't know no I do not
know oh fish maybe i dunno okay don't
know why I need a fish then oh she's so
happy yeah oh my god the fish I'm very
sorry ah she's such a vegetarian isn't
she right let's um why do we need fish
though that's like a kid why am i doing
all the stuff guys why am i doing you
know thread flow cold-blooded son that
your body dance to the rising stream I'm
so baffled by that one I honestly have
no idea oh yeah like I take money your
lemons they doesn't want any us to take
any of his lemons but
he does invite us to the pass it here to
join me in waiting I have to go home so
maybe he can give us a ticket to the
party the universe is your home that's a
very nice thought what's us now would be
my thoughts so the darkness won't haunt
me sweet though I see no darkness my
goodness is really bad I have to go I
can't believe you farted what what hmm
samee well the fish was part of it okay
we've got two more things to do you
definitely can't go in there you don't
have a ticket oh look flower
alger has Dawn's
let's cut the flower
cool what's the flower for this whole
episode is just me clicking on things
and going cool hey at least I haven't
cheated I haven't had to go and ask
Google what's due yet guys I totally
might have cheated but I need to
progress okay this all for you it's just
so we can progress this
how this person and it cut a hole i
guess maybe it's obvious whatever
whatever but this wack so now when he
goes to take a little basket to the bar
one will hopefully for like yes like an
overall minh hopefully i think there
might be all the things now i don't know
if a flower is one of the things but i'm
hoping that it is yag man sucks at
riddles fingers crossed which one is the
lemon shinies the sandbar at nope oh
yeah yeah yeah yes so this is although
you're not shiny but whatever number two
and then you can be number one darn it
the flower is not even an ounce okay
well what have we got left cold as I am
but if you burn me something blah blah
blah right yeah but if you use me I'll
be burning hard we had it with us this
entire time so annoying yes we did it
making progress I smell victory I smell
delicious victory congratulations thanks
mr. wizard dude
thank you sir I'm ready let's bring the
stones back hey yes we'll start the fire
coat room has awakened courtroom is
alive on the top of the mountain he'll
be waiting for you he has my lovely was
it had bring you to me uh your heart yes
the stones are hiding in my wizard tools
such ever wonders well that's why I
can't remember a thing oh but now i'm
remembering go to the top of the
mountain and find courtroom this is the
talking mountain finally come back when
you have the Hat then we can do the
other things alright so i'll bring your
heart yes then we can then we can start
becoming human again but i don't know
guys what do you think is fine look
better as a human or a tree culture me
look awesome
are you ready for this oh gosh week we
up I can't do this ooh transient really
low race is coming out like oh my
goodness you're alive i'm sorry to
bother you sir I'm Fran Fran I see I
don't know what that means well I don't
really know what it means either it's
just my name oh oh right My Mind's
kottaram do you want to know why tell me
kotra means born in heaven and I used to
be a star because i was born in space
it's very logical you have a mountain
was born in space were you that tall of
a mountain wow I've never met star in
person thank you no thank you nice to
meet you know so much you drew France so
what brings you up here the great wizard
told me to get the Hat so if you don't
mind hmm can't do that I'm divorced Oh
what does the beat divorce but LEDs
David a hat I just say the hat size very
important I can't if I give me the head
the entire land will suffer you'll have
to find another way to get home what the
king told me there is no other way
please help me I told you I can't my
wife left me she was the one covering my
charm what was your wife was your wife
the islands I saw in the water nah if I
take off the Hat my magma can I raft and
kill everyone including you oh now or
what happened between you and your wife
she uh she decided it was time to start
her own Island damin is it is that
little island
in the water she's his wife she broke up
with me I didn't get a chance to ask her
why I miss her so much ah I know where
she is should we ask him anyway I know
where she is she's her own Island I
don't know where she is oh wait no I
think she's on the water otherwise i
would feel her presence yeah we know
where she is she's definitely on the
water my love maybe love is away ah poor
Karim I'll go and see if I can find her
all right then you can give me in the
Hat only if she comes back otherwise you
know what can happen can I just like put
something else on your head surely magma
would I it so it's magic okay fine it's
magic fine can I fit in the ELSA top of
your head me and Fran on the same
wavelength I honestly didn't even read
that she just said that like a rock or
something instead no I liked it at all
right I'll be right back I'm gonna leave
it there we are gonna go and get
Mountain kottaram back with his wife in
the next episode beginning we will match
makers I hope you enjoy the random dark
creepiness that just seems to randomly
come in this game and surprise us and
I'm really looking forward to playing
more of this for you have a look at
everything bye look at the dragon ah
it wasn't it was Oh Falkor I don't care
what the name is mr. pellicle elantris
sir it's hot you look really bad